president trunk meeting with world
leaders during a high-stakes g20 summit
president trunk set to face off tomorrow
with his Chinese counterpart amid rising
trade tensions and earlier today Trump
signing a possible NAFTA replacement
with Mexico and Canada the u.s. MCA is
the largest most significant modern and
balanced trade agreement in history all
of our countries will benefit greatly it
is probably the largest trade deal ever
made also to many many jobs are already
planning to come back many companies are
coming back and we're very excited about
that
meanwhile back home the media and
Democrats primarily focused on Michael
Cohen's plea deal and developments in
the Russian probe it's become very clear
that the Trump campaign colluded with
the Russians in trying to subvert the
election I was watching yesterday and it
downtown sounds like a crime boss this
is just the beginning you're gonna see a
man with all kinds of nefarious ties
financially dependent period and this is
the first chip to fall today's the first
day I actually thought Donald Trump
might not finish his term in office
really this is not the way a high
elected official is supposed to talk
it's the way guys talk to me when
they're wearing orange jumpsuits and
explaining why they got done wrong all
right so Jesse they're kind of jumping
ahead here yeah they've already
convicted the guy and said he's a
collude herb but that's fine it seems
like in the media every day they believe
is the last day of the Trump presidency
I've been saying that since the
inauguration I've been watching the
Clinton affair on a na and it reminds me
of when he was trying to knock out deals
and protect the country and improve the
economy and he had this nasty special
counsel on his back and he kept saying
over and over and over again put this
aside let me go back to work for the
American people I have to work and help
the country and what have the voters say
at the end of the whole spectacle he had
the highest approval rating ever because
he was all he wanted to do was work hard
for the American people
if I were Trump I would do the same
thing I would just stop with the
witch-hunt texting and the tweeting I'd
say let me get to work and
look what he's doing speaking of Clinton
his signature trade deal
he's now rescinded it and repackaged it
so American autoworkers dairy producers
energy-water wine all these industries
are now in approved position he held
firm on steel and aluminum and it puts
him in a really strong position when he
meets Chi tomorrow over the China trade
war and we're winning that trade war
right now the Chinese economy is off 30%
since that trade war started they
thought those retaliatory tariffs were
gonna bring political pressure to bear
on the president that did not happen
Trump only lost one soybean district in
the midterms and if you look at the
whole big picture Gregg always likes to
say look at the results the results are
strong you just have this really negging
special counsel on the other end which
makes his life miserable
Gregg might have a metaphor of sorts yes
thank you for serving me up this
wonderful opportunity might I use a
metaphor Trump is like an ice cream
store with amazing flavors you have
wages and cream you have gobs Oh jobs
gobs Oh jobs economy crunch oh you have
optimism swirl you have North Korea
caramel and where is the media there
across the street feeding out of a
garbage can their cheeks swollen with
rotten fruit and vegetables because
that's all they want is bad news and
that's what you saw in that montage a
bunch of gut they all have Trump success
denial disorder they can't bear the
thing is I'll even admit like I learned
a lot about trade I don't I don't like
where he was going with trade but I had
he forced it on me I had to learn about
this imbalances that I didn't want to
learn about because frankly I'm an
opinion person I don't want to learn
about trade I just want to shout about
it but he forced me to learn about it
and I realized you know what the guy
cares about it the guy turns out he's
right he's getting stuff done and
instead these other you know creeps else
we're just too busy obsessing over the
garbage can filled with rotten fruit and
vegetables thank you oh my thank you
very much want do you think the trade
war is working the trade war with China
yeah well obviously
I mean obviously you look at the stock
market and you know most of the gains
for the year have disappeared and
obviously you have stuff like GM you
know 14,000 jobs that's a lot of jobs
Dana and you have things like
harley-davidson carrier they've left the
country country in terms of jobs a great
disappointment to President Trump so I
don't think it's working the question is
whether or not as Greg was saying you
know you look at the China deal is it
the fact or is it the case I maybe I
meant Jessie we don't alike you do it is
it possible is it possible that in fact
China whose economy is in a slump is now
on the defensive and more willing to
deal with President Trump we don't know
that yet in terms of the NAFTA deal let
me just point out that a good
conservative organ like The Wall Street
Journal said this is just basically the
status quo it could have been worse
given Trump's protectionist instincts
but you look at what is highlighted in
terms of the NAFTA deal and that is
dairy farmers and you say well is it a
much better deal for American dairy
farmers well it's a 1% or a little less
than 1% increase in the quota of
American dairy allowed into Canada but
there is now a situation where Canadian
prices can't be dumped Canadian dairy
can't be dumped in the United a Senator
Chuck Schumer well but the question is
whether or not Schumer and the Democrats
approve and we won't know that for a
while Emily I'll give you the floor you
can talk about anything that you'd like
okay then I will start by saying I
really appreciate your University of
Washington Huskies out out to us winning
the pac-12 championship go Huskies on
Chuck Schumer I will say that he
obviously voted nay in 1993 against
NAFTA and what's happened since what
have we heard from him since more
shouting about it without substance
no offense that I just pointed to you
when I said that so from him coming
forward and saying now this isn't this
isn't doing us any good he doesn't make
any reference to the class 7 pricing
system being gone in Canada and what
things are achieved and for me as an
American citizen I don't understand why
compromise hasn't been achieved this
entire time hasn't been reached I don't
want my elected officials to be standing
and shouting for 20 years without
anything accomplished because it's
compromise that
are all sending them therefore because
otherwise they're not serving us and
there will be absolutely nothing gained
on China I think that obviously the
trade war is significant and there needs
to be more leverage gained and mentioned
of the IP theft going on the erosion of
quality and also they're flooding our
country frankly with illicit drugs
there's a lot of talks about southern
border physical penetration it's also
happening in the air supply and with the
mail system so I think there's
overarching issues that need to be
included in that conversation but
certainly again those elected officials
they need to be a little bit more than a
whiner and a last word to just quickly
with Juan's comment I have to respond on
the economy and the stock market I know
you're weeping about your 401k one but
thank you for saying that it's the
makeup if you think about that you said
the stock losses you know that we're
back to square one since the beginning
of the year I mean I think we know why
that happened the tech sector is not
doing well and the Fed has been jacking
up interest rates and what did the
president making of interest y'all boned
down the Fed and now Powell has a much
more dovish approach which is why the
market ripped this week because he came
out with comments and it hinted that he
was going to take a more dunnage
approach and not raise rates as much as
he was indicating that's why you saw the
big jump in the Dow and his job on the
Saudis into cutting production which is
why this is $70 a barrel to $50